hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode8 of my buying and selling in Pay
toplay series uh we're going to go to
100 Mil using the granic change only um
we're starting this episode at about
10.46 mil uh we're in the green stack of
money now which is exciting I actually
had to go add up all the totals from our
last flip because I didn't actually
check in the clip um on a side note I'm
actually going to be gone for another 5
to 6 days at the music festival in
interior British Columbia for those who
don't know that's on the West Coast of
Canada um but yeah so let's jump into it
here we have some new items lined up
today so we're not going to do much of
the potions we're just going to do some
brand new items and we're pretty
successful um so yeah let's jump into
the first
flip okay so we're going to start the
episode with a redwood log flip uh it
has about a 40 GP margin on it which is
pretty decent uh we bought them for
about 1160 and we're going to sell them
for 1,200 um so we'll get a couple
thousand of these we'll probably do like
four or 5,000 and we'll get a couple
more items as well okay so actually I
think we might do a ring of wealth flip
again it still has about a 3K margin on
oh what okay the log's bought already
that's good it's kind of weird they
actually all bought all at once but
anyway yeah we bought them for 1161 uh
so we'll plop them in here for 1,200
that's actually always nice as long as
the margin didn't shift too much no yeah
it's the same okay yeah we'll put these
in for 1,200 anyway uh the rings of
wealth have a 3K margin on and for the
item price that's actually really good
it's about 10% you're getting back so I
think going to use the rest of our money
on the rings of wealth here um I kind of
like just having two items going at the
time it's a little less complicated but
we'll go buy a couple hundred of these
uh we'll probably get about 150 almost
yeah 150 perfect okay so we'll come back
uh when these rings have bought and sold
so the flips are in and we were actually
pretty successful the uh Redwood logs we
got a 40 ggp margin on pretty well uh
and we got about 5,000 logs we got about
190k from those and as you saw that
actually instantly B bought pretty well
um which was kind of Lucky but still
I'll take it and the rings of wealth we
actually got nearly a 3K margin on each
one and 150 of them um so we almost got
about 450k from the rings of wealth so
they worked quite well although I got a
little lucky and they did kind of
randomly raise up for a day or two so
we'll have to check and see if these are
still good going forward uh but yeah
let's give them another shot and we'll
find some new
items so the profit on the rings of
wealth has dropped down but you can see
there it's only like 1.5k but
realistically that's still actually
pretty good um so we're going to go
ahead and put it in for the low price
and buy 200 of those which will use the
majority of our cash deack um we're
actually on day two so we only have a
couple more days before our membership
needs to be renewed um so we're going to
be mindful of that but we'll get a
couple more items for
sure and next I think we're going to try
to buy a couple Infinity hats um we're
just checked to Budd and the low price
is 28 28k so we'll plop an offer in for
two of them and hope they buy it's kind
of our first um attempt at buying a kind
of rare expensive item um so buy only
two of those and we'll try to use the
rest of our cash for sure and lastly
here is kind of a filler item we're
going to actually do the energy potion
it's kind of nice to have these kind of
Cheaper items it only takes 5 600k still
have a really good return on it but I'm
still not going to be focusing on them
but it's kind of nice to just be able to
use the rest of my money uh never feels
that great when you have a bunch of
money just kind of sitting around cuz
it's not like it's getting interest or
anything so uh yeah we'll go ahead and
buy 2,000 of these and we'll check back
when this stuff is
sold so the infinity hat actually worked
really well we got I think about 120k on
each one and we got two of them so
that's about 240k from the infinity hat
so that's pretty nice um the Rings we
didn't get nearly as many as we wanted
so we only got about 56k from the Rings
um we got about through 2.5k Marg on
each one and uh the energy potions we
got about 81 GP margin on I think I
calculated and that gives us about 35k
in total um so not too bad still got
about 300K on the flip I think we're
definitely going to try these Infinity
hats again um so yeah let's go buy
another set of infinity hats the one
thing I don't like about flipping high
value items is there's a lot of guess
work involved unfortunately like you can
look at the low price which is somewhat
accurate but I mean here we're plopping
in for 28 45k uh we don't really know
what people are buying this on it for so
there's a lot of guessing could be
waiting a long time not sure if you
actually have the proper price or not um
but yeah so we'll buy three of these and
we'll find a couple more items okay so
we'll put a quick offer in for energy
potions as well um they have about a 40
GP margin on it so that's an easy
80k and lastly we're going to do the
super attack potion has a really good
margin on it and I can't really complain
about that because we are buying them
instantly you can see a quarter of them
have bought um so we'll check back when
the infinity hats have totally bought
and some probably the potions have sold
this as well okay so the infinity hats
have sold um we got bit less of a margin
this time we
got a 54k margin on each one but we did
get Three Hats this time so we got 162k
from the infinity hats which is pretty
decent um the energy potion we broke
even on and the super tax we got about
70k in profit from um so I think we're
going to focus again on trying to get
some more items like the infinity hat
but first of all actually we have to buy
a bond um because we're on day one and
I'm not sure when my membership expires
so we're going to go buy now fortunately
I think the price of the bonds is
actually dropped I think the last one I
bought was almost 3 mil and oh y we
actually buy it so yeah this one was
about 600k cheaper which is really nice
I'm not really sure at what point I'm
going to maybe buy multiple bonds at
once CU it is more efficient to get
spend more to get like five bonds at
once cuz you get three months see right
there um but at the current moment it's
a little too detrimental to buy more
bonds at once cuz it'll lower my cash
stack too much um but right now we're
actually still sitting at 9.2k or 9.2
mil sorry um which is pretty good
actually so I might consider buying two
bonds next time so we'll go ahead and
redeem the bond and we'll come back when
uh we got our first item so I think we
might buy some of these Infinity hats
now I mean like look at this chart I
mean it is useful for sure but at the
same time almost be worth it just to buy
and sell one to actually see what the
margin is um instead of wasting your
time and trying to guess it but um right
now we're just going to try to buy some
for about 2.8 mil um we'll give it a
shot I mean we're just kind of a shot in
the dark here we have actually no idea
what the price is but that's kind of
half the battle when you're doing this
so we'll get one more item as
well and I think we might do this super
defense it looks like has a pretty good
margin on it that's actually really good
that's almost 200 GP if we buy it for
the low price which I think we might um
so yeah it's 400k if we buy for the low
price probably more like 250k if we buy
it for the high price um so we'll put in
for
2046 and we'll
buy don't think we can buy 2,000 but
we'll get pretty close um so this is
pretty good um going to see if the
infinity hats buy if they just kind of
stagnate we will pull them
out okay the hats have been sold and at
this time we got about 75k on each one
uh it g us about 150k in total um the
defense itions we got 115 GP on each one
and we got 1,700 of those giving us
almost 200k so pretty decent actually
for just the two flips so the infinity
hat has been working pretty decently so
we'll go ahead and buy a couple more of
these again we're kind of plopping
random prices we're kind of just feeling
around putting the price up a bit and
lowering it down it's pretty much all
we're doing and we're going to buy three
of
these so next up we're going to do
actually the am of Glory trimmed it's
kind of a funky item but it has a decent
margin on it so we buy it full for 6 61k
in a little bit and we sell it
[Music]
for 52k yeah so that's pretty decent
we're going to buy probably like a 100
of these since it has about an eight or
9k margin which would be really awesome
we buy all 100 not expecting to because
I don't know who the hell actually has
this item um but yeah we'll buy 100 and
we'll probably get at least one more
item and lastly we're going to do some
energy potions uh we actually insta buy
them which is nice um they still have
about 30 GP margin on it so that's easy
60 70k uh which is pretty nice when you
only have about like under a mil left um
so we'll go ahead decant these quickly
and uh we'll plop them in at the high
price which I kind of forget now but um
let's see yeah we B for 386 and we're
going to sell them for like
570 or something yeah 573 yep so uh
we'll come back when this stuff is
sold okay so the flips are in and we did
pretty good the infinity hats had a 28k
margin on them I think and we got two of
them so that's 56k the energy potions we
got 43 GP on each one and 2K of the
potions giv us about
85k the glories we got nearly 10K on
each one unfortunately we didn't get 50
of them but we did get 10 giv us another
100K um yeah so it's pretty decent way
to the end the episode I think this what
we're going to call it um but I think in
the end we made about 1. 7 mil um this
episode and we did renew our bond so we
started the episode about 10.4 mil um we
ended at 9.8 mil but um we bought a bond
which cost us 2.4 mil so after
calculations we made 1.7 mil so thanks
for watching guys if you enjoyed just
hit that subscribe button and I will see
you guys in episode
[Music]